a little bit of like friction a little
bit of bad blood between Microsoft and
um and Joseph but I don't think it's
like to the point where
like there could never be a scenario
where they work together in the future
because I feel like if that was the case
after Halo infinite he just would have
left he there's no going back he would
have just left and I I think that you
know she was unsure if he wanted to stay
Microsoft that's why he just transferred
to another uh portion of the company and
I think probably sat down he's just like
look you know I did what I could and you
know it's hard to tell what happened
behind closed doors maybe Microsoft
maybe he fought for Halo incident in a
lot of ways we don't know because we
didn't sleep on closed doors and maybe
he didn't get what he wanted in those
kind of scenarios and maybe he's just
like look like you know I I want out and
dude's been there for how long how many
years it's like looks like sometimes
when people leave it yeah yeah 17.
sometimes when people leave it's just
they're burned out